that's how off the bitching what's up
guys how you guys doing
it is about 135 a.m. I have a flight out
to Oregon I got booked last minute if
you guys don't know during the spring I
do a lot of college tour so I do a lot
of stand-up and motivational speaking
and I used to do a lot of stand-up years
ago it was it wasn't my original passion
and dream I wanted to be the biggest
stand-up comedian on earth and obviously
those dreams changed Asian girls you
will I always lie about your situation
I'm with somebody right now yeah give me
like a fake number wanted him to go to
hell she gave me the same number you
guys roommates or something same switch
to YouTube we what Oh buddy
ring all the clips put home be home be
giving up on stand but I'm still doing
it but my flights at 7:00 so which means
I have to leave in at 5 a.m. so I
thought I could stay up I can't do it
I'm [ __ ] tired or when I'm coming to
you I hope it's gonna be dope and uh
laughing my [ __ ] if you don't y'all
something's wrong with you I don't know
you might be a serial killer besides
your body's bonafide won't just butter
that Sunday best yeah see I
what's going on you guys have interior
children of the airport I've been
watching this man with his thumb in his
face for about 25 minutes I'm wondering
what the [ __ ] are you listening to that
is so deep that you got a thumb in your
face but 25 [ __ ] minute on my
way to organize for mention except only
about a couple of hours I'll try to stay
up all that said she's [ __ ] tiring
man I don't know why you guys wanted my
face so much my mom didn't want to see
my face that often that she you know
gave birth to me so but I will see you
guys soon
shits a [ __ ] [ __ ] man this is my
last show on this tour so it's a service
to you guys because you guys me
supported me so I'm just gonna do it for
you - makes introduce yourselves and I'm
Wilson it's really odd talking to
yourself with a group of people you know
it's funny cuz a lot of youtubers do
this they walk around yeah and they talk
to themselves and I haven't done this so
this is very weird for me I feel this is
incredibly like narcissistic no I love
it when hey Claire does it I love her
who is that see I don't know any
youtubers II learn what you mean
what does hate Claire do how am I
supposed to know who the hell she is
why'd you make it sound like she does
something that's relatable to me as a
human being she doesn't make up who's
who Suzy my favorite channel on YouTube
is not even my channel it's this channel
called cooking with dog hi I'm Francis
the host of this show cooking with dog
good morning welcome to cooking with a
dog I've [ __ ] loved that channel
why
introduce yourself I'm new I am Asian I
I think that's like pretty
self-explanatory exact Bolton I think
we've already met party can do this
season when they pick me up my
girlfriend Michelle that can't help it
you stole my heartbreaker honest man
make you look like a Vietnamese Jenny
sook try lesbian compass we have a
daughter
he's the cat know everything well that's
a little weird you're probably get that
checked
but it looks like immigration here [ __ ]
this is great so I've recently decided
after talking with a lot of the
youtubers that they they told me that I
should do life vlogs which is [ __ ]
annoying but a lot of you guys want to
know what I do on my personal life I
have no idea why is a lot of
masturbation but I decided to uh this is
actually gonna be the very first video
that I'm gonna release is my trim my
very last show
I'm gonna shut the [ __ ] off yeah and I'm
like my privacy like our business
oh no that [ __ ] did it I was like girl
pick it up and she's like no and she
laughed in his nose or she kicks it and
I'm like pick it up and she's like no I
saw it oh yeah oh did y'all put like
baby oil on yourself and wrestle it out
you what I'm gonna do I'm a lighter
vagina on fire let's do it she put no
stress
so what restaurant are we at right now
what is off the waffle no for apples
meat the worst [ __ ] beer pong partner
on [ __ ] earth day absolutely screwed
me over I'm gonna do dirty things to you
I went to go into your mouth this is
getting really weird now what do you
think of your doughnut it's very
delicious describe it to me he's really
sweet with a subtle texture and I don't
[ __ ] each other why describe your
doughnut one more time so the deep fried
texture and we things out the moistness
going on guys
I am over here at a Eugene Oregon just
got done with the show my flight is
delayed about close to three hours all
of this Airport and it was the last show
on the UH on the college tour so I'm
starting back up in fall ourselves but
uh yo man it was a super dope show thank
you for having me come out
I can't wait to go back got to get back
on this funny fat fake grind get back
into the gym started itching up that
short film and getting back to us I hope
you guys start or hope you guys are
enjoying these life loves you're not
then what the [ __ ] you've been asking
for you know months about a show deal
with it
hello everybody I am back in California
just got the hook-up back in California
about to go eat some Thai food for pot
ward it's my favorite noodle place in
the US I'm gonna get a number one with
the rice no doubt and I making some
papaya salad up about how
pulip style